[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
e
et
m
[Musique]
oh
bah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
encore un poid
[Musique]
à
hautmont
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici bon attendez
là on avait dit allez moi ça va bon
alors on était là au fond précédant
l'entrée vous voilà
et ça monsieur olivennes mais les morts
ah ça oui
voyons le coffre
vide naturellement pas encore vous
appelez du chant auguste antoine toute
l'histoire romaine mon père était guide
au musée du louvre quand exactement avez
vous découvert le crime à deux heures
dans des jeunes et j'ai pris ma blouse
comme d'habitude dans l'atelier de là
c'est comme ça exactement
oui
peinture c'est à dire non il était il
avait la figure appuyé sur le parquet
allongé sur le ventre libre en 3 c'est
pourquoi été placé comme ça maintenant
c'est moi qui l'ait bouger là parce que
je ne savais pas qu avant l'arrivée de
la police pour toucher à rien ah non je
savais pas qu'il était mort il va
falloir leur maître communauté moi oui
que je touche indispensable
alors allons vous aider était-il dans
l'autre sens mais bon oui à tête
oui mais sur la joue gauche comme ça oui
et pas remarqué la plaie la base du
crâne
pourtant les vies des coups de matraque
clan ben ouais je dis travail allons
allons retourner votre sang-froid quoi
vous êtes le seul à pouvoir nous
éclairer bon allez oui bien sûr jusqu'à
présent vous êtes le seul témoin je ne
sais rien j'ai rien vu je suis arrivé à
14 heures comme d'habitude le patron
avait pas enlever le crochet de la pente
quand je suis rentré pourtant il a bien
fallu ouvrir avec une clé pour aller
vous chercher
j'ai ôté le crochet et pris la clé 100
points n'importe qui pouvait pénétrer
avant votre arrivée pour quelqu'un à feu
les savait montrer bien du sang froid
qu'est ce que vous voulez j'en reviens
pas moi même
mais quand la police est ici avec vous
devant ce pauvre homme il perdait les
pédales
j'ai plus rien c'est nerveux mais qu'est
ce qui me gêne car je me sens très en
danger venir d'un peu c'est pas un
modèle courant une punaise marque ad
avec la tête de celluloïd voyez c'est
moi qui les ai achetés ce matin j'ai
pris ce que j'ai trouvé
voilà la boîte
reste à en fixer ce dessin au mur que
monsieur olivier frappé par derrière par
votre avis peut-être oui sont coupés
l'assassin est allé au coq service qui
contenait le coach est pas exactement
quelques bagues de l'or du platine de
l'argent enfin tout ce qui est
nécessaire dans le métier opère quelques
diamants peut-être pour quelle somme se
penche sur l'hiver était qu un artisan
atteint d'après ce que je vois
il travaillait pour quartier rue de la
paix ah oui mais ce travail là ils
l'exécutent à lui-même avec tes des
pierres et des métaux qu'on lui
apportait et vous je préparais surtout
les montures vous avez tout de même
l'habitude d'une estimation
oui il y avait combien dans le code au
minimum c'est pas ma d'hitachi quoi
qu'on se fasse une idée un million
peut-être pas seulement alors là les
réfléchissez mourier 1 les pierres de
l'or du platine est sûrement arrivé à
votre patron des dépositaires de bijoux
d'un prix plus élevé or il en a eu un
jour pour plus de 10 millions à la
pensée d'avoir ça dans son coffre il ans
dormait plus le chiffre du coffre vous
le connaissez elle ne tremblait pas vous
le connaissez mais où nos noms augment
assez pas une réponse bon alors autre
chose comment expliquez-vous que
l'assassin ait pu s'approcher de votre
patron sans attirer son attention parce
qu'il est évident que seule une personne
familière un de confiance non l'athlète
chez nous sommes bien d'accord
non c'est pas moi c'est pour moi
n'importe qui pouvait l'approcher sans
qui sans doute parce qu'il était dur
d'oreille
c'est moi qui prenais ses communications
téléphoniques
bon alors n'importe qui venant de
l'extérieur pouvait entrer ici sans être
entendu de lui en ce sens je le jure
portez pas d'appareil oui on n'avait pas
besoin il disait très bien les paroles
sur les lèvres
à vérifier parlez nous maintenant des
clients qui venaient ici des bijoutiers
mois il sagement doute pas de clients
particuliers si il enlevait même deux
provinces mais rien que des gens qui
connaissaient ou qu'il eut été
recommandé par méfiance
non mais quand on n'a pas de boutique
qu'on travaille sans publicité la
clientèle se fait surtout par relation
faudra dresser une liste et un
répertoire rêver bon alors si je
comprends bien mais qu'ils sont votre
patron avait dans ce coffre des millions
de pierres précieuses
ils étaient sûrs comme un pont il
possédait aucun moyen de protection et
en plus quand vous étiez sortie il
laissé sa porte ouverte à tout venant
1 autrement dit l'ami beaucoup de
complaisance à se faire assassiner
avouez quand même que c'était très
gentil de sa part
attend il avait un moyen de défense et
seulement il a besoin de saint servais
connaissez ce ravageur
non oui enfin c'est à dire que jouer
voyagera jouer les idéaux bon je vous
jure j'ai dit comme ça maintenant la
vérité la vérité
ben coups de poings américains ont dit
voilà c'est un joueur c'est une
commissaire sert à jouer
amusant d'ailleurs vous n'allez pas
encore mais il est à mon fils je suis et
confisqué pendant le déjeuner parler
d'un amusement pour les gosses l'eau là
où vous vous parlez une coïncidence
société papiers et ben bien ils sont
dans ma veste dans l'atelier et vas-y
lacoste
normal
il donc bien voir ça avant de mieux en
mieux que c'est ça des diamants oui je
vois bien mais qui sont ils un monsieur
olivet monsieur tu nous dis c'est avec
le plus grand calme
bien sûr il me les avait confiés pour
faire choisir à un ami encore une
coïncidence mais non mais ça arrive
souvent quand les gens de mon quartier
veulent acheter un bijou ils ont intérêt
à penser par moi je leur obtient des
prix ce choix est destiné à qui monsieur
roussel roussel roger et qui s roussel
rejet c'est un ami qui habite thionville
il est agent commercial dans une affaire
de métallurgie il mangeait chez moi à
midi comme il voulait faire monter un
bijou pour sa femme monsieur olivennes
avait confié ses quatre diamants pour
lui faire choisir il ya quel at elle est
descendue se distinguer convient il
il n'a fait que passer par paris lors
pris l'avion à orly à 2h30 pour
l'afrique du nord toujours les
coïncidences 1 voyons voyons vraiment
rire on la trouvait surtout un coup de
poing américain avec lequel qui appuient
à ce mets ton patron les pierres
précieuses qui lui appartenait et puis
libellé et de distiller soi-disant un
certain monsieur roussel est toujours
par hasard ce monsieur roussel vient de
s'envoler pour des terres lointaines
tu crois pas que le hasard joue drôle la
vedette en histoire c'est pas le hasard
c'est le manque de chance vérifier ce
que je vous dis ta femme et ton gosse
leur témoignage pour moi c'est zéro ton
navigateur je dis pas mais alors il faut
attendre qu'il revienne en attendant moi
je t'embarque vous ne vais pas m'arrêter
je vous jure que c'est pour moi je sois
pas si nerveux qui tu es innocent qu'est
ce que tu as à craindre une erreur
judiciaire mardi
qu'est ce que je fais avec la victime
bon j'arrête reste avec monsieur georges
qu'est ce qui se passe comme légères
vrai volet judiciaire est ce que vous
voulez j'avais rendez vous à trois
heures avec monsieur olivennes je suis
un client et mille choses et
représentant de commerce bijouterie non
leurs fleurs des plumes
désolé mais monsieur olivennes pour
apercevoir pourquoi ces phases arrêtées
non ah bon à l'aube à 17h d'avoir un
agent la police et hig
ça fait supposer le pire oui monsieur
hallyday mort paie-t-il assassiné après
possible pense à alain assassiné mais
pourquoi
pour le volet on l'a aussi voler
d'avions nettoyer le coffre fort peu de
bijoux que rien à les misérables des
bandits la branche de ma pauvre maman de
la prison mais ça j'en ai peur mais
c'est une tragédie monsieur le
commissaire une tragédie qu'est ce qui
inquiète ce qui se passe on m'a dévalisé
monsieur peas et jacques deux camps
spécialement pour prendre livraison des
bacs et voit la méfiance a gâché par une
joueuse en faire une tête haute avec une
idée au moins une piste
les présomptions alors il faut faire
quelque chose il faut tomber ma bague
mais n'y a pas une seconde à perdre
or quand je prends un calme et revoyons
penser qu'il ya un mort à côté
bon c'est vrai excusez je ne pensais
qu'à moi aussi à l'hiver vous
connaissiez depuis longtemps non je
n'avais vu que deux fois
c'est madame bernard la charcutière a
comme j'habite qui m'arrêtent adressé à
lui il a fait pour elle des dix jours de
l'ue prince moi c'est plus modeste
j'avais apporté à ce pauvre homme pour
la faire transformer en bad moderne le
branchant briand qui me donne ma mère
elle m'avait dit un jour ce sera pour
pas culturefemme com je me suis
soudainement penser monsieur ni
d'aminata modèle presque identique à
celui de quartier pour 40000 francs dire
que si j'avais pu bien vierge
qu at il été entre midi et 14 heures
ah oui j'étais dans le train j'envie
directement de la gare vous croyez qu'on
la retrouvera soit à la bague attendait
d'abord qu'on ait retrouvé l'assassin
bon sens tout d'abord une petite idée
les soupçons une pipe prouver que diable
ses autres métiers
je regrette mais la crosshair n'est pas
là quant à l'employée on ne peut encore
rien dire mais vous pouvez me donner
tout de même l'espoir que je vais
retrouver ma main mais qui chez moi la
paix avec votre bague et peut-être 10
millions de bijoux dans le coeur voir
votre petite bague baettig monsieur
olivennes avait estimé un rien que pour
les pierres à plus de cent mille francs
alors
sais tu pas un maharadjah pour 400 mille
fois avec le sourire je vous avait été
volé qu'est ce que vous diriez vous avez
été assassiné vous n'allez tout de même
pas me reprocher je ne me reproche rien
c'est une constatation avait tout de
même que vous avez plus de chance que
monsieur olivennes alors on à la loi
pourquoi pas s'il en est mort mais non
pas du tout simplement il ya une
question de priorités dans une enquête
que tu me manques je me plaindre à mon
député ça alesi et si ça ne suffit pas
de faire la grève de la faim non de
l'impôt se paye donc vouloir balayer
marc hutter marché bon chemin de fer et
me défendre contre la faim je comprends
votre indignation mais alors asseyez
vous et calmez vous une seconde je veux
bien
les gars est au milieu
or tard de l'intérieur
mais voilà
vous êtes calmer oui eh bien je vais
t'arranger cette affaire ah vous êtes
optimiste
ouais en attendant moi je les attends
obligé de retourner à caen sans la bague
de fiançailles vous voulez la
description du bijou non inutile je
crois pouvoir vous rassure et nous
allons le retrouver
j'espère bien mais quand aujourd'hui
même en double une bonne nouvelle pour
les faire des courses et puis je
repasserai et c'est dans la soirée je
prends le dernier train s'il le faut oui
vous êtes arrivés par lequel le 14h25
canada vous demandez vous étiez entre
lisieux evreux au moment là tu as you
n'a été commise à peu près oui pouvez
prouver comment je voulais vous avez
rencontré des personnes de connaissance
non non pourquoi
bah
alors comme ça vous ne pouvez pas
produire des témoins certifiant que vous
étiez bien la stran des témoins si vous
parlez en descendant du train je me suis
aperçu que j'avais perdu mon
portefeuille alors j'ai fait des
recherches dans le compartiment dans le
wagon des employés de la gare montée des
gets même signé une déclaration monsieur
vous avez aussi perdu votre portefeuille
oui si les mains aujourd'hui vous n'avez
pas de veine heureusement encore que par
précaution j'avais mis les 49 ans dans
ma serviette
sans ça bon on va appeler la gare 16
vous objets trouvés
alors gare saint-lazare objets trouvés
s'il vous plaît objets trouvés ici
commissaire prévost palais judiciaire et
en début d'après-midi auriez vous s'il
vous plaît enregistré une déclaration de
perte de portefeuille est formulée par
un nommé emile choses et de caen si vous
ne me croyez pas je veux bien aller à la
gare avec vous ne me reconnaîtront non
inutile alors à bon os books avait
enregistré la déclaration bien à bord
ils vont faire une description de la
personne oui alors ça pour être grand
élégant
quelle couleur la serviette bon
parapluie rouler et chaussures de grève
bonjour merci
alors vous êtes fixé maintenant c'est
bien moi qui ai fait la déclaration n'a
aucun doute c'est bien vous vous voyez
bien que j'étais dans le train de 14
heures vous étiez à la gare et dans le
trajet une autre histoire c'est un monde
puisque l'on m'accuse est honni par anna
c'est ça je vous préviens que je porte
plainte en diffamation et ça vous
coûtera schaller aisée vous comment on
ne vole je perds mon portefeuille
marie-louise la mangue irlandais rapport
à ça dingue il faudra encore que je me
tate à pain l'empoigné well employés
vous voilà je suis bien venu ici
recommandé par madame bernard la
charcutière actor madame perna la
charcutière de corps elle est venue ici
teintant fois oui oui c'est exact vous
avez vu la broche que j'apportais pour
la transformer ces mêmes vous qui m'avez
montré des cinq bagues peur bleue bien
sûr vous deviez revenir aujourd'hui un
jeune le luth à partir à trois heures je
me souviens oui j'avais fixé cette heure
là à cause de l'arrivée de mon train en
effet vous voyez bien
voilà une dame de caen qui me rendent
parler de la ville de caen madame
bernard parce que libellée panda tiens
mais ce que je faisais dites donc qu'est
ce que je vous ai fait c'est pourquoi
vous n'avez pas voulu me dire bonjour ce
matin mois la gare en partant vous
eiffel ou pour qu'on voyage ensemble
j'étais avec monsieur volée mais vous
savez filet dans les wagons peints je
vous ai pas vus on n'aurait pas par des
voyageurs étaient moins long j'ai à me
commander des boucles d'oreilles comme
j'en ai vu un glyphe feu hier dans la
dame aux camélias
mais ne vous dérangez pas pour moi mais
ce que je vais attendre mon tour victor
matioli b qu'est ce que vous avez comme
client aujourd'hui ça marche et affaire
suit la grille et j'oublie toujours
qu'il est sûre comme accru son aide à
quoi qu'est-ce qu'il ya qu'est ce que
j'ai dit d'abord pourquoi il ya un agent
à la porte
madame monsieur olive est mort qu'est ce
que tu dis il a été assassiné comme
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible et
là c'est vous aviez des bijoux en
commande
non il m'avait livrer la dernière petite
chose que je mettais faire il ya déjà
trois semaines
vous êtes de la police et vous avez une
idée de la sas a une idée de plus en
plus précises brageot et vous allez
pouvoir m'aider moi comment en disant à
quel heure monsieur josé a pris le train
ce matin accor quoi vous soupçonnez
monsieur fusée c'est un ami c'est
comique
avez vous pris le même train tous les
deux matins oui ou non j'adore ce cas là
moi je ne sais plus je croyais l'avoir
reconnu je puis vous trompez vous pensez
bien que si vous m'aviez fait coup je
vous aurez reconnu se remonter avec vous
en tout cas une chose est certaine n'est
ce pas madame c'est l'heure d'arrivée du
train que vous avez pris à quelle heure
est il arrivé à saint lazare à 11 heures
bon je vaux rien c'est maintenant les
choses sont claires comme de l'eau de
roche
mais je ne garantis pas que la personne
à qui j'ai fait ou était mais ce que je
suis c'est inutile de faire machine
arrière sur madame au besoin nous
interrogions ce monsieur bonnet avec qui
vous étiez
je vous garantis moi que si lui a
reconnu monsieur vous et moi je vous
embarque pour faux témoignage on vous ne
ferez pas ça monsieur vous fais pas ça
et 0,6 et non-arabes le commerce esee
vous tu peux tout avoué maintenant peux
te dire comment monsieur li vé a été
assassiné sur une recommandation de
madame qui vient le voir pour faire
transformer un bijou à ce moment là je
veux bien croire que tu ne savais pas
encore capable de tuer au cours de
l'entretien monsieur river ouvre son
coffre fort qui aperçoit des diamants de
platine de l'or des millions de nature à
tenter
dix représentants en fleur et fument
tous vous ton plan est très simple tu
prends rendez vous officiel pour
aujourd'hui trois heures tu arrives à
paris à 11h par le même train que madame
et je mettrais ma main au feu 4 quand le
prix du billet pour paris en sortant qui
en gardent un étude l'autre à plus de
voix dit écrire des films policiers avec
toi oui d'accord tu arrives ici entre
midi et une heure tu monte l'escalier
olive et là tu entres avec la plus
grande facilité
tu traverses l'antichambre
l'atelier
tu aperçois dans le bureau les v en
train de fixer un dessin au mur avec des
punaises
il est sourd il ne tentant pas à coups
de matraque lui défonce le crâne
ils tombent les clients sur le kof
tu as envie de le contenu et tu files
comme tu es venu j'aime vais vous dire
que les accusations de ce genre et
devant témoins ça va vous mener tout
droit en taule ouais pour qui conduire
par la main le smo finir pendant que je
vais lancer ou as tu mis des bijoux
volés pendant le monde en un paquet à la
consigne est vers 14h15 tu prends un
billet et tu attends l'arrivée du train
de corps dès qu'il est là tu sors ton
second billet tu te comportes comme un
véritable voyageurs en ayant bien soin
de te faire remarquer naturellement
l'histoire du portefeuille perdu et et
autres malice formidable plus sûr de son
alibi l'arrivée si vers 3 heures pour
être exact au rendez vous fixé devant du
chant et voilà mais avec des
déclarations de ce genre pour dix ans
visé le curé de la madeleine en prison
et cher guillotiné le président de la
république écouter vous n'avez pas de
preuves je vous montre à tous la preuve
que c'est bien lui l'assassin
suivez moi la preuve la voici
vous avez une poudre aux yeux
ce matin les gens à acheter une boîte de
21 punaises et étriers marcadet j'ai
demandé à mon assistant de conté il en
reste combien dans la boîte vingt-et-une
et celle qui est aux murs avait 22 or
monsieur livet été tué pendant qu'il
s'apprêtait à planter les trois autres
en avoir trouvé une parterre que sont
devenues celles qui complète la boîte
celle qui nous désignerons l'assassin
voici voilà les deux punaise manquantes
ah ben ça alors je suis pour rien c'est
le hasard qu'elle met en quête voir tous
très envie de faire une cigarette tue
m'attendent et un briquet il m'a échappé
des mains
je me suis baissé pour le ramasser et à
ce moment là qu'ils étaient outrés sur
ta chaise les jambes croisées en train
de balancer son pied droit sous le nez
c'est toi même qui m'a montré que l
assassin quand on veut conserver sa tête
monde qu'il faut regarder où l'on met
les pieds
[Musique]
je voulais rendre au collège
mais ça je le garde
nous le confie c'est mon tour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
présenté par christiane voici le passant
des dames et des demoiselles oui et
comédien prévôt ac toi mais le cas sous
des tentes et des uns est excellent mais
ouais tu au bureau un dimanche
tu veux l'augmentation quoi c'est que
c'est urgent un coup de téléphone d'un
gars qui appellent au secours est il
tombé dans un guet-apens il a subi deux
coups de poignard dans le dos aux
abattements vieux mais on ne fait pas
assassiner un dimanche jour de repos il
est sûrement dans le coma il a à peine
eu la force de raccrocher son téléphone
et what is gonna à saint cloud tout près
de cette attente c'est pour ça que je
t'appelle un oui il a eu un fait de la
force de me le donner
chez une madame aubigny 22 rue des
réservoirs huitième étage non non il
n'ya qu'un appartements par étage
on va qu'est ce que tu veux il faut y
aller mais tu te rends compte je devais
emmener tentes et dix à l'opéra comique
en matinée là tout de même il faut y
aller et voilà tantine qu'est ce que va
me passer dit donc en sautant dans un
taxi je pourrais être leurs dix minutes
comme ça ils se répandent perdu ton
cassoulet et de raccrocher jamais douté
[Musique]
bon mais ted ajas taper
ota
alors
une bagarre c'est une bagarre
reproduction mais réussi
montherlant cocteau maria gide
voyage au congo illustré par d'araignée
tirage chaque exemplaire
ouais
à l'opérer il y aura 200 m 4
à lacoste et dans le bas était mort et
bien moi je suis arrivé trop tard oui
oui et chez madame bobigny mais sa
huitième étage juste à temps un voyage
des sens j'ai la conscience pour
l'interroger
madame bobigny c'est une personne très
bien prêt comme il faut elle a acheté
ici il ya à peu près six mois les mario
non elle est veuve et guy seul sans
domestique et pourtant je crois qu'elle
a de très belles rang ont acculé la
voilà qui arrive à aubigny commissaires
après vos balais judiciaire oui il ya
longtemps que vous êtes sorti votre
appartement ils n'iraient pas put in un
jeu vous allez déjeuner au restaurant
pourquoi parce qu'il ya un cadavre chez
nous c'est une plaisanterie non madame
pas du tout la victime a téléphoné à la
police à laisser votre adresse
mais arriver le plus vite possible
excusez moi je suis entré avec un pass
mais trop tard c'est ta mort que j'ai
trouvée au milieu de votre salon
mais voyons c'est pas possible vous êtes
trompés des tâches vous êtes bien mal à
bobigny vous habitez bien huitième étage
oui bon alors aucun doute lui un crime
chez vous mais c'était plus rentables
c'est à n'y rien comprendre
marcel vite chez moi vite via malabo
minutes monsieur quel étage je suis avec
madame week-end
8e
mais bon s'il va te dire une chose
pareille est-il impressionnant je n'ai
jamais pu bien à mort alors mr abbas a
par exemple qu'est ce qu'il y a le
cadavre a disparu ça mais je deviens fou
mais si c'est une plaisanterie monsieur
je la trouve douteuses
à mon âge je n'apprécie plus vite madame
je vous jure que ce n'est pas une
plaisanterie il n'y a pas plus d'un
quart d'heure il y avait ici un gala
ouvrez vous en prie je vois là tu vas tu
arrives bien il m'arrive quelque chose
de fantastique
le temps de descendre une remontée plus
rien je ne retrouve plus rien de ce que
j'ai vu le cadavre disparu la chaise a
été réparé le vent acétate tu ne crois
pas qu en dix minutes on a le temps de
faire disparaître un cadavre il
remplaçait avant une chaîne de zahoui a
remplacé la porte glace et nettoyer le
tapis au point qu'il n'y a plus la
moindre trace de sang il essaie avec le
tapis jamais de la vie en face quelle
loi que j'ai vu le portrait de madame
aubigny je les ai vus la reproduction
j'ai eu la laddh a pondu je les ai vus
les bouquets hd et vu cocteau mauriac
montherlant gide sont pas seulement vu
tout de même ce qui a soulevé de ne pas
saisir
non non non non non non à genève a dit
qu'il fallait prendre des vacances ils
sachent comment ça je crois à temps
décidément que je me repose aurez vous
s'il vous plaît l'obligeance de nous
mais bien volontiers mon pauvre monsieur
heureusement j'ai la preuve formelle que
je n'ai pas rêvé
voilà le seul papier que j'ai trouvé sur
le canard c'est un billet pour les
folies bergères pour la soirée d'hier
awilo date et un exo par dessus le
marché mais des billets gratuits un
effet du poids normal à moi je ne sois
un artiste ou une danseuse qui les
paient le prix fort à la direction pour
en faire cadeau la victime alors
constituer leur ai acheté le billet
comme tout le monde
oh c'est pas la même chose sauf
peut-être les gens d'aller au spectacle
à neuilly et j'ai l'impression d'être
quelqu'un n'importe comment la direction
va nous dire le nom de l'inconnu ou tout
au moins celui de l'artiste qui a vendu
le billet keller était 3h et makengo
folies bergères je saute je fais mon
enquête
il trouve un gant une danse jusque dans
le pool interroge et après la filature
toi tu t'occupes de la vieille dame
et si elle sort que la suite le lâche
pas d'une semelle et tu fais surveiller
les études immeuble est entendue et dans
ce biais là c'est peut-être la clé du
mystère
on ne sait pas
mon collègue vient de me persuader qu
effectivement j'ai besoin de repos alors
il me ramène chez moi voilà je suis
désolé de vous avoir causé tant
d'émotions mais je vous en prie motivés
et mes gars en ont assez
bonjour madame habits ni s'excuser mois
à la sortie des folies bergères j'ai
beaucoup de mal à trouver un taxi
c'est vrai vous aviez matinée le colonel
c'est fait oui
voici votre salaire ont travaillé soit
bad
grâce à vous seul n'aura pas eu le temps
de s'organiser le réseau qui devait
contre battre à celui que nous avons
créée au prix de tant de sacrifices
on sera content nous là bas mais
j'aimerais tout de même un rapport
détaillé comme vous l'avait ordonné de
l'arrivée du sol qu'à paris il ya quatre
jours je me suis arrangée pour me
trouver sur son chemin il a été très
heureux de vous revoir
nous avons évoqué de tant de souvenirs
et tous les soirs nous avons dîné
ensemble
ainsi que nous l'avions prévu m'a
demandé si je connaissais un appartement
meublé
je lui ai indiqué celui de madame
aubignat saint cloud je veux être
téléphoner en sa présence
je lui ai passé l'appareil elles ont
convenu d'un rendez-vous pour
aujourd'hui
13h30 il est venu chez moi à l'heure
convenue
je lui ai fait visiter l'appartement est
revenu dans le salon je les fait asseoir
en lui demandant la permission de me
sentais une seconde pour aller chercher
des v rally que cette colonel golden
globes qui rentrait et qui l'a frappé de
deux coups de poignard élevé solde s'est
dressée nous nous sommes battus et le
temps de casser une glace un vase le
terrain et nous avons vider ses poches
pour qu'en aucun cas ils ne puissent
être identifiés ils viennent
l'ennui c'est que nous l'avons cru mort
sans coeur ne battait plus n'est-ce pas
seulement une fois que nous l'avons
équité il a dû retrouver la force pour
l'ancien sos à la police un inspecteur
et heureusement il n'a trouvé qu'un tel
il est descendu c'est la concierge
quand ils remonter avec madame aubigny
notre dispositif de sécurité a
parfaitement bien joué je dois dire que
la uris mandat des commissaires et du
plus haut comique
elle comprend en tout cas j'ai eu la
visite d'un policier cet après midi au
cours du spectacle avant vous avez
peut-être vider les poches de soldes et
vous avez oublié le talent du geek je
lui avais donné pour la soirée d'hier
l'inspecteur me l'a montré elle a voulu
me faire avouer je l'avais donner un
en grand blanc est maigre qu'est ce que
vous avez dit que j'ai voulu faire une
amabilité monsieur de province petit
assez gros qui venait de me tall un très
joli cadeau et vous a demandé son nom
oui j'ai répondu n'importe quoi monsieur
dupuy à la rochelle je crois mais
j'avais ajouté que j'étais sûr qu'il
m'avait donné un faux nom pour garder
l'incognito ont beaucoup de provinciaux
qui vient s'amuser à paris j'aime mieux
je crois à la bac en vain qu'il m'a
laissé tranquille mais il vous laissera
pas tranquille je suis sûr qu'il vous a
suivi il n'y avait pas de voitures
derrière mon taxi moment où vous en êtes
encore aux méthodes filature dit dation
canton qui sait si votre chauffeur
lui-même n'était pas un homme un e
mais il fallait pas venir c'était la
dernière imprudence j'avais besoin
d'argent bon allez me parler d'argent
quand il s'agit de et échapper à la
police vous croyez qu'ils vont encore
interrogé l'essentiel sera le goût terre
ils ont des moyens pour faire parler
je les connais qu'importe pour la
mouteyre cessé de trembler comme une
petite fille allons essayer il est trop
tard pour trouver maintenant vous
oubliez à quelles conditions vous avez
été épargnée il ya deux ans ou au
terreau et quoi qu'il arrive pas qu'on
vous fasse
j'espère
vous êtes stupides
allez prendre un petit whisky camera
dans les voir tout ira très bien sans
aucun comme d'habitude
la river
marceau livre
non pas par là vous allez sortir par
l'escalier de service vous trouverez les
rue la pérouse
il ya très peu de chances qu'un policier
ou gage de ce côté là
vous êtes sûr qu'elle ne parlera pas
absolument sûr parce que dans 5 minutes
elles soient morts comme on vous l'avait
empoisonné une embolie dans la rue ça
peut arriver à tout le monde
excusez moi alors
bon merci c'est marcelo lippi est
lui-même 2/5 dit que les policiers ont
levé la surveillance et qu'ils sont tous
partis filer la balle j'arriverai un
quart d'heure plus tard là où vous savez
pour mettre le canada dans une malle
cabine que je sortirai l'immeuble comme
si je partais en voyage on est lesté de
service vous aussi on ne sait jamais
parmi ces bons trades à l'instinct à ce
que je vois je n'aurais pas volontaire
et qui dira encore je ne me sens pas
très bien
qu'est-ce que vous avez je digère mal
oui c'est mon cadavre qui ne passe pas
permettez
la fête
qu'êtes vous allez faire dans l'hôtel
particulier d'un certain golden boy
soi-disant exportateurs de produits
chimiques rue dumont d'urville
c'est un vieil ami à moi nous ou aux
échecs tous les dimanches
pourquoi êtes-vous ressorti par le
service ou rue la pérouse
je trouve que c'est plus court pour
gagner les toiles et cette danseuse de
claquettes de folies bergères pourquoi
est-elle venue
c'est la fille elle de votre banque
pourquoi est elle ressortie elle aussi
par la rue réfère aux pour la même
raison que moi je suppose c'est vous
qu'elle est morte cinq minutes plus tard
sur le trottoir potable pauvre petit
souvent arrivé à l'arrêt du coeur dont
nous recherchons ensemble la cause qui
vous voulez bien être prévenu son
parrain
quand deux de mes collègues se sont
présentés chez lui il avait disparu
qu'en pensez vous vous voulez vous que
j'en pense je ne suis pour rien dans
toutes ces histoires mois chère madame
on bénit j'ai beaucoup réfléchi au sujet
des hallucinations et je commence à
croire que je suis moins fatigué que je
ne pensais pas que je dirais même que je
suis en excellente forme
permettez
exactement ce que je pensais
il ya une terrasse au-dessus oui
qui habite l'appartement du dessous un
monsieur thiberville je crois vous le
connaissez nous saluerons dans
l'ascenseur toutes les issues de
l'immeuble sont gardées un vrai
pénitencier tout le monde peut entrer
personne ne peut sortir s'ils voulaient
descendre avec nous mêmes mais c'est un
ordre
qu'est ce que vous faites
laperne aller les bras en l'air et
autres le maire
pas bête
pas bête du tout
fallait y penser
ici seul huitième étage c'est d'ici que
je suis venu la première fois je
reconnais tout par le cadavre a disparu
voilà les traces de sang sur le tapis la
chaise briser le base la porte glace
on nous appelait pas thiberville mais
golden borg
je vais prendre la préfecture le double
c'est la photo de votre passeport pas
tout possible et bien avec vos amis je
crois que maintenant tout est limpide
mal à bobigny achète un appartement du
huitième
vous seriez ne vienne et comme il arrive
souvent dans certains immeubles la
tentation des murs est exactement la
même c'est alors que suprême astuces
vous faites mais bel et deux
appartements d'une façon strictement
identiques
ceci fait vous attirer votre victime
dans l'appartement les huitièmes et une
fois votre crime commis par celle qui a
votre complice montrera désormais tous
ceux qui demanderont madame aubé qui
n'ont pas de huitième étage mais où la
vienne
l'ascenseur est encastré dans le mur
allez donc savoir à quel état je vous
arrête exactement
d'autant plus qu'il n'ya pas de chiffres
inscrits sur les paliers
maintenant j'ai un monsieur j'aimerais
savoir où se trouve le cadavre bon
d'accord c'est à défaut il va des noms
c'est inutile je ne sais pas un criminel
de droit commun comme il sait je suis
officier le sert une cause mais c'est
mieux ça me permettrait une question et
je vous entends lacoste emmène alors
comment es tu arrivé à découvrir notre
combinaison grâce à un détail infime
vous avez tout acheter en double mais
c'est golden bourg mais sauf une chose
ceci vous avez tout simplement oublié
que dans une édition originale il n'y a
jamais de volume qui porte le même
numéro
celui ci que j'ai trouvé là où 9e portel
numéro 97 et l'autre est dans la
bibliothèque là-bas portent les numéros
oui ça m'est venue après coup parce que
tout de même 13
c'est un chiffre qui marque
et bien voilà 13 qui ne vous aura pas
porté bonheur
exact vos appels
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à bec
pas bête du tout
[Musique]